- How many baseball games you been to?
(bell dings)
- This my first one. This jawn crazy.
- It's your first one?
- 100%.
- This is my first one too.
I don't really be going to too many,
like, professional games,
like, as a fan.
- This jawn tough though.
And, you feel the energy
'cause it's a playoff game too!
- Yeah.
- He look like
he about to do damage though.
Boom! I told you.
(crowd cheers)
I told you, I told you, I told you.
(crowd cheers louder)
I told you.
I told you he 'bouta do that...
(both laughing)
I told you he 'bout to do damage!
- He hit that s--t out the park.
I'm telling you, boy.
- They jawn players,
because they can all wear they chains out there.
- Oh, yeah.
- You s--t like that, huh?
(both laughing)
Oh.
(crowd cheering)
To the crib.
- It look like it.
- He got to score, though
- How'd he get to score?
- Because he touched the base and ran.
- Even on the out though?
- Yeah. So you gotta wait for him to catch it,
then you gotta touch the base, then you gotta run.
- The baseball season be so long.
- So long. How many games they got?
(upbeat music)
- Don't get me to lie. I don't know.
- It's like double basketball.
And I know basketball season long too, though.
- Maybe about eighty two, maybe. And they be in
different cities damn near every other day.
- Yeah. Come on now, r--
Come on now.
I almost said ref.
I gotta say say umpire, right?
(fans laughing)
- Hello! Get him outta there!
- C’mon, ref
Yessir!
(crowd cheering)
- I told you
- That’s what I’m talking about
- Go sit down!
- Don’t worry about it, baby. Get him outta there.
- You know like in baseball,
they switch pitchers every game.
- Yeah. 'Cause they can't pitch
too many times in a row, right?
- I don't know.
I ain't, there's so many little ins and outs with baseball
I ain't know about.
- I know them boys goin' all offseason.
I mean, all season.
(crowd cheering)
- I know that's a strike.
(fans laughing)
- I say, if I ever played baseball,
I don't wanna bat, I don't want none of that.
Put me in the outfield somewhere.
You see what I'm saying, bro?
That's a hundred miles per hour.
S--t like that.
- I would swing too.
- Nobody got time for that.
(fan laughs)
- He got a good song.
He got everybody singing with him.
- Everybody know the song.
♪ A O, A O K ♪
- That song probably gonna
be in my head all night.
♪ A O, A O K ♪
(fans laughing)
- He got his same routine every time, boy
- I've been watching, everybody a different one.
- Yeah.
- He be doing the same jawn with his knees.
- He about to do it again.
He do that jawn every time.
Then he gonna tap the bat.
- Ah.
(crowd chanting)
- Oh.
(crowd cheering)
- Outta here.
- Get out, get out, get out, get out.
(crowd cheering)
Ah!
- It looked good. It looked good.
- Bomb. Oh, let's go.
He taking second?
- Nah, he ain't gonna take second.
- Yeah. All right.
You trippin’, you better go back.
(fans laughing)
He a kid ain't he?
- Yeah, they the ball boys.
- Oh.
- I've been saying,
Look, it's gonna be a little kid from they team
that ran out and get the gloves and all that.
I know he love his job though, boy.
- Aw, hell yeah, he having fun
- That's lit.
- In front of all these people?
- Strike.
(fan clapping)
- I know what that means. Strike.
(fan laughing)
(crowd cheering)
- Got two of 'em.
- Oh.
Oh.
- Watch this when when he do that sh--t
That s--t gotta be in that little box.
- Yeah. So you looking at it right here? I’m over here tryna-
- I did it 'cause she was looking at it.
Then they tell you where the ball placed at.
- Yeah.
(crowd and fans cheering)
- He out.
- Get him outta here. (fan clapping)
- He knew it too.
That was too high, boy.
I don't even know why
he swung at that one.
- Ooo!
(crowd cheering)
- Come on, come on!
- Let’s go!
(crowd cheering)
- S--t that got serious!
(fans laughing)
- Might well this s--t going.
- Might as well.
Oh yeah.
(crowd cheering)
- Come on!
- Let's go.
- Oh yeah!
- Whoa!
(fans laughing)
(fan clapping)
Yeah!
- This s--t turnt
- It’s all lit
- Oh, they switchin’ pitchers again?
(announcer commentating indistinctly)
- Goddamn
- I told you.
Get out of there, get out of there!
(crowd cheering)
Ow!
- Come on, come on!
(fan clapping)
(crowd cheering)
I told you.
- Come on, you the one
that need to take us home.
♪ A O, A O, A O ♪
(fan laughing)
- He said, "A okay."
♪ A O, A okay ♪
- [Both] Ah man.
- Fall, fall, fall,
fall, fall, fall, fall.
(crowd cheering)
(fan clapping and laughing)
- They don't wanna play no more.
They don't wanna play.
- They back to AZ, man.
- They out there confused!
(crowd cheering)
- Go home, go home.
Go home. (clapping)
- Send them back to AZ, man.
- 10 nothing is crazy.
- Yeah. They want to get back to AZ.
It's too cold out here for 'em.
- Yeah.
- They uncomfortable.
- I ain't know baseball games
was a vibe like this though.
- Nice, bro.
- I gotta come back to
one of these, though.
- For real.